what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to
myself on the kevin samuel show got a
lot of comments about it i know a lot of
you saw me on the kevin samuels show
um i called in about a week ago and
yeah it was it was pretty fun but i was
i wasn't nervous as hell
so um before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
gotta lower it down because i gotta run
the show
that's it
[Music]
so how about that folks to my to the to
the women who joined the show
the women who come over here you heard
me say it what can i do better
what can be done better from men's
content
from your standpoint to help
you do what you need to do to become the
woman you need to do to come
to become a better woman for one of
these men
because telling me what we can do better
if you're not going to be willing to do
your part
so i'm willing to hear it
i'm willing to hear it kevin you can do
this better you can do that better
it would be better if this that's i
definitely couldn't think of anything
off the top of my head because i was so
nervous
oh my gosh i was so nervous the whole
purpose of having my
biggest fear is to be one of those girls
that gets that like 30 second clip and
just says the wrong thing
oh no the interview segment and the
middle ground segment i've said it
before
this show is this this platform run by
me but it ain't about me
i'll get what i want by helping people
get what they want um
you gotta be seen in the zoom call uh
if you're on zoom okay i see you in the
uh
participants okay
all right so essence you ready
you gotta wave if you're ready essence
all right let's go i think i was after
essence
so everybody here hold up some comments
she just bounced out
um pearl yeah that's me
sorry i'm a dork
they could not hear me though so i'm
gonna tell you what we talked about
hello yes i can how
hi how how are you
that's okay how i said i was good i'm
just a little nervous
that's what i said what are you 24.
all right what do you got for me
so i started talking about how i need
men because i literally can't do
anything
i can't and i know you guys will take
that
as i only need men for chores but i
think there's something about
appreciating the fact that men fix our
cars men
you know are the plumbers electricians
whatever i could not survive without men
my brothers are a godsend and my dad oh
my gosh
a godsend
yeah this is me just saying this for
like five minutes but i was so nervous
so i'm actually glad i was muted at
first
okay uh are you
unmarried at this point um i said
that i had a boyfriend were you raised
with your mom and dad
yes i was
okay um
do they have strict gender did they have
traditional gender roles in your
household
meaning your mom did stuff around the
house go ahead
um so i said that i have nine siblings
so it was like
somewhat normal but we had a nanny so
they helped but my mom did more of the
like
girl stuff obviously my dad did more of
the boy stuff but we did have a nanny
and my mom did work
you said you had nine siblings yeah he
was shook
jesus hmm
where are you from
oh okay oh yeah they can't hear you
okay so um no this is pearl pearl was
saying basically
tell everybody what you said earlier you
can't do what
you're saying you can't actually go
ahead oh i couldn't survive without men
um just like personally like um like i
wouldn't be able to fix the tire
or like do any of the like traditional
like manly
stuff um like every time i move
i need guys to help me every time like
my car breaks down my dad helps me like
yeah i could not survive um
hold on just a second uh vera
then i got kicked off i wasn't
interesting enough
hello i said that you could tell when
i'm more nervous because i use
like 10 times more i say it too much now
but i use it 10 times
more she just clicked off
vera yes oh my gosh this lady was crazy
so you can you hear me don't don't go
away yet guys i come back on
but i want to point out my reaction to
this lady because she's a nightmare like
this
yeah i can hear you just fine hold on
pearl i'm talking to beer yes very how
old are you
vera i'm i'm 48 my birthday was my day
okay happy birthday so what do we got
what are we talking about today
well i don't know i really didn't have a
question
it was interesting you brought that
topic up i will say i appreciate the way
you
kind of keep us in line and checking us
when we
go too far and saying things about men
because i've done that before
too not like that but i i like how you
brought that that's the first time i've
ever heard you do
um bring up a subject like that so i
really didn't have any question but
um i really enjoyed the topics that you
bring to the table
they kind of cut me but it is what it is
are you uh hold on just a second are you
married
i am separated i will be soon okay
just a second i'm going to bring these
two people up stay here viewers stay
here pearl i'ma meet you ladies but
you're still here
sir i was demoted demoted you're not on
in essence are you ready
hello essence how are you
hi hi i'm good good how old are you
i'm 30. all right what do you got for me
um so i do agree with you
um and the fact that i feel like modern
women we
won't they don't like men
not for what they really are and what
they really can
or what they really are supposed to
provide when it comes to
what they suppose they're supposed to
add to the household and to the family
and the role that they're supposed to
play
okay uh are you are you married
single what i'm married okay how long
you been married
five years okay you can always tell a
married woman your energy is different
when you come in
do you have any sisters um
from my dad i do i have two sisters
okay um are any of them mary
no okay all right hold on just a second
i'm gonna get to
some of the single ladies who may have
more of a disagreement congratulations
on the five years though
thank you all right sarah let's get to
you
hi sarah i'm here yourself
sarah i'm mute yourself
hello hi sarah hi how are you
good how old are you 36.
all right so what do you got for me
um well i've just recently been
introduced to your platform uh my
brother introduced me to your platform
my younger brother
and i uh i've already learned so much i
don't think i was aware
of what a modern woman i was
my personal responsibility for the
situation that i'm in
uh so just to give you a little
background um
i'm egyptian and um i'm went to memphis
lady seems so nice
and i always thought in my head that i
was a traditional woman like oh i want
four kids i want to get married but all
my actions in life were focused on my
career and i heard one of your talks
about
how women use school as an excuse to
kind of protect yourself because you're
really afraid
and that is a little phd and um
so do you want to be married you want to
be married
yes um
[Music]
how did you say you were again 30 36
30 you want how many children
well whatever i can get now all right
no man when i know yeah let's go ahead
give you the no man's land
[Music]
are you an actual physician you're
medical school
i'm a physician i've been a physician
for
five years now so what is it like being
a physician
because from your 20s you're focused on
undergrad medical school residency
now you're a fully baked physician you
you're doing the work
you got the career going you're getting
the money now what
exactly um
it's just that it's just going to work
and coming home and then
not really having anything else how many
hours a week are you putting in
i was working a lot more than after the
pandemic
uh i i work less now so i work a 40 hour
work week now
regular schedule nine to five monday
through friday
so i'm going to assume as a physician
you have the means are you working with
the things i say image consult with
therapist immigrant
therapist image consultant personal
trainer matchmaker
i um only have the therapist part right
now
but um because you are 36
because you're 36 time is not on your
side
you can't move slow you got to move you
got to do everything all at the same
time
right so i think that um on a practical
level i don't really know
what to do because i haven't exercised
that muscle so i wouldn't even know like
what a serious matchmaker would be and i
always get very anxious kevin should
recommend matchmakers actually that
would be a good idea that's what i mean
a new man i think i self-sabotage
so i don't know how to get through that
with the quickness that i need to
well hold on a matchmaker will sit down
and assess
who you are what you want and
the okay like i tell the men i'm going
to tell you
so what you're scared you got to do it
scared
y'all women i get it women don't women
aren't used to rejection you don't like
it
too too bad because what's the
alternative
do it one at a time slow and you'll be
40 years old
and then try things really drop off the
cliff
personal trainer that is something you
can do tomorrow
right then why not
yep i was talking to someone about this
the other day some people don't know
that they don't want to do anything
because you'll ask them like if they're
doing anything and they they're not you
know
what i'm saying is what i'm saying is as
a professional let's
let's talk let's tackle this as a
professional you have the means right
and you don't seem to be enjoying the
means you have the resources
but they're not giving you a higher
quality of life so
money is a tool hire a personal trainer
high nutrition guys i swear i come back
on you just gotta wait for it
hire an image consultant her matchmaker
or else have resources
and a couch all right
and then pick either a dog or a cat
seriously seriously because at least
you're in a position where you have the
resources
now spend them right
okay let me get to someone else um
all right it's only ladies so if i see
guys pop in here i'm going to just
boot you out i'm not dealing with guys
um
let me say this again ladies make no
mistake if you're
over 28 you're going to have to spend
money to get a man let me explain
if you're over 28 and you're over a
dress size six
you're gonna need to get in gym and
getting in the gym
is not a problem joining a gym is not
the problem the problem is going to be
getting a personal trainer to get you a
workout plan to get you
fit in shape and on something that you
can maintain
for a lifetime somebody to put their
foot
square up in your backside to keep you
mobile a big believer in coaches
if i wasn't potentially moving
in a couple weeks i'm gonna get a
trainer
pretty soon this isn't an excuse guys i
might be playing
in england in two months so i'm trying
to see what happens first
motivated stay on that diet someone to
hold you accountable
then after that
and then after that having somebody
after you like what you see getting out
of the shower
you're going to need to dress it
then you're going to have to actually
take it out on the road
go out into the world and actually
interact with me
and risk rejection all things being
equal if you don't do that then what
i think women deal with rejection more
than men think
it's just the rejection for a
relationship
not for a hook up but remember and i
know men don't feel sympathy for that
because
in their head you still get sex so who
cares but women don't want sex they want
relationships
so it actually i've seen a lot of girls
get really messed up by not getting that
relationship come back to pearl real
quick
i'm back sorry
uh pearl i'm gonna meet you do you want
to be married
um yeah i do uh uh you want children
yeah and you come from a family of nine
wow how many kids well ten total
jesus i had ten
[Music]
yeah including me ten wow uh
yeah wow that's unusual a little house
on a prairie should happen
so how many kids do you wanna have
i don't know um i'd be happy like
between two and four i'd say
okay that's three okay this pissed me
off i didn't say anything
okay between two and four
all right guys i used to want five dogs
i got one dog
i'm good with one dog i don't want any
more dogs i'm golden maybe when i have
like a house someday but right now
i'm cook that's cooked i'm good
same thing with kids i know i don't want
an only child
right um
so at least two i could see myself
having four but i'd be good with two
between two to four not
three like if anything i'll probably
have two or four because if you have
three you might as well have four
anyways i just had a bone to pick i
didn't say anything i was too nervous
um when do you plan on when do you want
to get when do you plan on getting
started
um i don't know maybe
like late 20s i'd like to have kids
i thought about it i'd be cool with
early 30s i just want to make sure i'm
like married
before 30 basically okay
um i'mma say something to you and all
the women
you all need to be dating with intention
see dating with intention will require
you to actually
level up to what you can can truly get
meaning everyone has an idea of what
they want
but what's the likelihood of getting it
if you're not dating with intention you
said you have a boyfriend
in order to have your three children i'm
assuming you want to be married first
yeah in order to be married you got to
have a husband
if the guy you're seeing is a nice guy
but not a husband it's pointless
i'm not saying what he is or is not but
when you start dating with intention you
have to
you have to learn how to cut bait
because that's the reality i'm going to
go to vera real quick
that was the end of my that was the end
of it it's kind of funny though if you
look at
um my face during the next lady
like there were times when my reaction
was pretty funny
it's kind of ironic that we had that
conversation
with kevin with what happened in the
upcoming days but
i'm not going to talk about that anyways
um
do not forget guys um oh wait wait
i'm a restart i'm restart thank you for
watching
that was me on the kevin samuel show big
ball of fun
if i may say so myself don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification
bell that way you're gonna be notified
of my daily videos i will talk to you
guys next